hello everyone I'm very excited to be
here today all the way from Switzerland
to beautiful Australia and my first goal
I already achieved I arrived here and I
am coming from winter so I'm very happy
that I'm not red as a tomato right now
thankfully the weather is not that crazy
so this is not cause my new friend that
I made with my Pakman circle I really
love this analogy by the way it's really
awesome as was already mentioned I'm a
game designer working as a full-stack
developer at archaeologic we are startup
from Zurich that is working with 3d
interiors and architectural
visualization on the web and we are
basically working on a JavaScript web
framework where you can use our 3d
models and 3d API around 3d modeling for
your website I really really love games
I like developing games I like playing
board games video games and that's why
I'm here today to talk to you about
render engines and the second goal is
that you come out of this talk and you
know a little bit more about 3d and that
you know how to get started if you want
to so this is more of a low I will talk
where you will be able to learn
hopefully yeah I really like travelling
but I have to say this has been a really
long travel to come here I might have to
change this no it was really enjoyable
so far so thank you so much again for
having me so why would you want to do 3d
on the web I mean the web as it is now
it's really great we can do lots and
lots of things why do we need 3d so
first of all 3d adds another completely
another dimension to the web that means
you can also use this dimension too
for your advantage to show more things
so this is a visualization that we made
and on top of this visualization we
don't only have a 3d model of a house
but we also have spatial data which we
can then use with our machine learning
algorithms to for example automatically
furnish your room and show you how you
could use this space that you have not
even thought about before or we can also
see where where you which which is the
room you might want to use for different
things or how the light is going to
affect your room it's not only that we
can also make a really amazing games on
the web it's and we can use all the
advantages of the native web that that
we have which we could not do with
applications that are just standalone so
this is a really cool prototype that ADA
Rose was doing in a very quick iteration
so I was really it was really fun to
play it right you can also really do
data visualization so this is a data
visualization from busy cities and what
I really love about this is that you can
not only use the third dimension to so
show that in time but you can actually
also use it to show a progression over
time so you can use animation and other
infographics to show these things so I
don't know how many of you have
experience with working out with 3d but
I myself was wondering how do we even
start with 3d and like we have we have
so many numbers with wire frames we have
polygons we have textures so many new
things that we want to to use and how do
we even get started it's very
overwhelming for for beginners I see
because I have been working with game
prototypes with 3d visualisations with
3d on the web with WebGL 3GS and it's
still a mystery to me and it's still
really hard to help people to get
started so my approach is a little bit
different yesterday we have heard lots
of talks about color and I really
enjoyed that was actually it CSS come
from sorry lots of color concepts and I
want to go one step behind that so I
want to talk about light and how we
actually see so let's take a blank scene
and we add this this scene to it we have
like a little chair and we have we have
a laptop standing on a desk we have some
shelves but we have a window and outside
of the window we see the Sun and the Sun
is shooting race or emitting rays unto
the earth and what happens is this race
come in through the window and they
start bouncing off the first object
that's in the scene and this light ray
has energy and the light is basically
gonna bounce until these energies you
stop well what does this actually mean
so light is electromagnetic waves with
different frequencies which make up the
color so if you take away one frequency
or two frequencies you might get red or
green but what do we actually see so
what happens with the Rays only the race
that are hitting our eyes it are
actually visualized on that on the back
of our eyes so how does it happen that
different objects have different colors
I'm gonna explain that a little bit
later as well
material surfaces have this thing where
they selectively absorb different
frequencies of light or an
gee and they can also reflect the
delight or transmit it so for a
visualization you could think about
these three different types and that's a
really big abstraction so you have
materials like mirrors or water
sorry mere mirrors or metals that are
[Music]
reflecting the light which means that
they are uniformly reflecting the race
and through the uniform Ness you will
actually be able to see your reflection
then you have things like diffuse
materials which are super chaotic and
they basically scatter the race all
around the place and you have propagated
light so if you have a material like
glass or water the light will not only
reflect off the surface but it will
actually also transmitted through the
solid with these three different things
so could somebody bring me some water
please
thank you with these three things you
can already create such a big range of
materials and we have not even talked
about the colors yet thank you so much
and I am I know this might seem a bit
random but I'm explaining this to you
because this is the problem I see with
people that are starting it's not just
if you get started with 3ds not just you
have to learn how to 3d model it's also
you are basically a movie director
you're a light specialist a photographer
you have to use lots of design to to get
to a point where you get some some nice
results you have to know about
sonography
and lots lots of other things so it's
it's like a new new big box to take
things out of and I feel that that when
I explained to people these concepts
they start to really understand what is
much a reality how do we create a
realistic looking 3d scene if we don't
know about these things
so we have now the concept of light but
how do we capture this light on an image
and for that it's really cool to go back
to the first cameras that have been made
and these are called pinhole cameras
which most of you have probably heard of
and what happens is that we have one box
with the tiny hole which basically only
allows us one light ray to pass per
pixel or in that case space on the film
and that's where the concept of ray
tracing is coming from so ray tracing is
a really substantial rendering technique
that has been around for a long time so
the first talks about ray tracing
engines were actually at SIGGRAPH I
think 1984 so that's six years older
than I am that's I feel pretty it's
pretty cool to see how long this
technique actually has been around
because if you think about computer
graphics you think okay it's just been a
few years since we have this GPU
acceleration and no actually I think the
first computer graphics animations have
been rendered with ray tracing and other
techniques that I will show you a bit
later actually then took over and for
real-time computer graphics as for games
but Pixar is still using it's a mixed
kind of a mixed thing but they're still
using ray tracing as their primary way
of rendering so what is ray tracing
actually if you think about the Sun and
it's emitting billions and billions
of race at every tiny little micro
second that's lots and lots of rays that
are bouncing around all yeah okay not
really in this video because it's quite
dark but that are bouncing around all
over the place and if we would calculate
all this race that would be a big loss
because what I've said before is only
the race that actually hit our eyes are
the ones that we can see so somebody was
really smart and came up with the
concept of backwards rate racing so what
we do is we go backwards from the eye or
from the camera in this case and we go
through the pixel and we shoot away from
our eyes into the scene and we see which
rays are going to hit a light source at
the end of them so these are considered
a primary race we want to see what is
the the main object that gets hit the
first one because that's the one that we
want to visualize and that's the beauty
of ray tracing is that we actually have
this understanding of the scene so we
know what is the first thing we're
hitting and what we do is very
simplified we do a test is this point or
this point of the on top of the surface
of the object is it directly in sunlight
or is it obscured by another object so
what happens is we hit the object and
from the object we cast a second ray
based on the reflection the cast is
second-rate there actually to the Sun
that's the simplified version right
sorry but gets a bit more complicated
since we have talked about materials
before right so what happens what
happens actually on the surface of the
object
what if our surface is transmissive so
what we want to do
it's not directly check if the Sun if
the point is in the Sun otherwise we
just get two values we get it's in the
song or not so what we actually want to
do is we want to see how much of our
light gets reflected and how much of our
light gets refracted or gets transmitted
through the solid and that's just a
mathematical equation that we can do and
from there we're gonna see if it hits
another object and then we go on and on
and on and at the end we want to see if
we hit a light source or not it's still
very simplified so I would like to look
at some code that does this concept I'll
give you a minute to really
yeah I think I think everybody got it
right so what is a common challenge
wrong people who do computer graphics is
to write the most compact ray tracing
engine that could actually fit on a
business card
so that's what people do in their free
time and I was giving this talk at Jays
come Iceland and right after me there
was Martin clapper doing a talk it was
called Daedalus was fantastic talk and
only recommend it but what happened is I
think he did show me an example that was
a fourth of this so please watch it it's
really cool I was I was very impressed
very impressed so there was almost no
typing involved I mean this is how I
feel after two weeks of looking at my
code just don't understand anything so
let's take this a little bit further
down and I took all the math out of this
because I think it's not really
something we should look at right now
it's gonna make it would add lots and
lots of slides so first we want to think
about the concept of geometries there is
lots of primitive shapes that we can
describe mathematically and one of the
easiest shapes are spheres because
basically what it needs to define fear a
sphere is the center and the radius and
boom we have a sphere right cool
so we're only going to do spheres for
the beginning what we also want to
define is the material so we want to
know what color does it have how
transparent is it and how reflective is
it so what we wanted wanted to find for
this objects or for all our primitive
objects that we're gonna program in the
future is an intersection function so
basically
we get the Ray the origin of the Ray and
the direction of the Ray and we do check
does it hit or does it not hit and if it
hits we want to know on which two
intersection points because there's
always two then we're going to have our
main function where we define our scene
this is gonna be something you're gonna
have to do a lot is you place objects in
their scene and because we have a
simplified version of a ray tracer we
only do spheres also our light source is
going to be sphere now and then we have
a frame buffer where we have for each
pixel we're gonna check and see we're
gonna trace our race for each pixel and
then afterwards when we have all the
image data we're gonna render that to a
canvas so this is how a trace function
could look like and the cool thing is
recursive because we all love recursion
we take some we take all our scene in
all the geometries we take the first ray
the origin rate which is the incident
ray that we have seen before and the
direction and then we also have death
because basically what I said in the
beginning we want to trace the Ray
forever until it hits the Sun but that
could take that could really take a long
time or sometimes maybe it doesn't even
do it so that's really a shame because
we want to do this real time in the
future so what we do is after the depth
of recursion that we define maybe five
times we do the check if actually the
object is in shadow or in the Sun and
we're gonna do this for each light
source in the scene and then we can
combine the values of the light sources
together and
that's where the physical correctness of
the raytracer is gonna end so if you
really want to have physical correctness
you would go for a path tracer that's a
whole other box where you really shoot
the race forever and see when they're
gonna hit something
where was I yeah so we're gonna find the
nearest object our first object it's
gonna be hit and for that we're going to
loop through all the geometries we do
the intersection test for all the
geometries and if we hit something good
if not we're just gonna return the
background color of our scene if we do
hit something we're gonna have to we're
gonna have to see what object material
is it's there so if we have transparency
or reflection we have to continue the
test because the Ray is going to bounce
off so yeah we're gonna do we got into a
recursion for each so we're gonna do a
reflection recursion and we're gonna
compute the refraction recursion and in
the end we're gonna put them together
with Renault and that's something I'm
not gonna explain it's really cool
though because it depends on where our
surface normal is so if we hit sorry
that was too early if we hit the object
it depends on what is the impact and
where's the where is the surface normal
pointing at and depending on that we
kind of change how we calculate the two
values of refraction and reflection
exactly so if we resolve the recursion
in the end and we compute the values
together we're going to get the color of
the pixel at that specific point and
this is what it's going to look like so
it's really interesting we already have
lots of things we have reflection we
have shadows
and these things come all for free with
its rate tracing you're gonna see that's
not so easy with other rendering
techniques so I have already gotten
ahead of myself a little bit what
strikes me or what was really cool in
this experiment is that everybody can
get started really fast to actually
write a rendering
okay so very little code we can do our
own render engine great but we're gonna
very fast run into lots of problems for
example what if we want more than just
primitive geometries that are but not
mathematically defined what if we have
multiple light sources that we have to
consider in our calculation what if we
have more transition transmissive
materials or materials that are
multi-layered such as skin so it's
somewhat transmissive but also it's
milky and get really interesting what if
we want more physical correctness yeah
what if we want to have more light
bounces and what if we want to avoid
noise in our scene because that's
something that we will always get with
ray tracing since it's basically one
sample per pixel is not going to be
enough we're gonna have to do lots and
lots and lots of samples and add them
together to get a really smooth image
okay so this leads me to two the second
rendering technique that's very
fundamental in computer graphics which
is rasterization and the interesting
thing about rasterization is that it's
really super fast and it can do lots of
things but basically what is the concept
is that it's solving the visibility
problem from a different perspective
while ray tracing is tracing from the
eye to the objects in the scene
rasterization is going the other way
around so it takes the scene and it's
going to go from the scene to the eye
with perspective projection so what we
do is we just
sickly flat map the whole scene onto a
screen space version of that and we are
using triangles for this because
triangles are an ideal rendering
primitive it's planar that means we
don't have I guess we can always look at
it in a 2d from a 2d point of view and
we we cannot we cannot make them any
smaller we cannot add more surfaces to
it so what we do is we map each triangle
to screen space and then we're going to
rasterize over it and see which pixel
lays in what triangle and with the C
buffer we're gonna see which of the
triangles are more in the front and
which one are more in the back and
that's how we're gonna render it so
these are two really basic
implementations one is a basic
rasterization implementation and the
second image is a basic ray tracing
implementation and you can see that as I
said before with ray tracing there's
already lots of things that you get for
free
for example the reflections Antti
realizing shadows soft shadows and all
these really cool things I think
everybody can see what is the quality
difference so how are computer graphics
solving this because if you look at
games these days you're not gonna see
the top thing it's going to look really
nice with advanced implementation there
is you can actually fake a lots of the
physics but we're getting to a problem
when it comes to transparency and water
and water simulation of fluids and
things like this so there is differences
ray tracing is physically correct
provides us with high details it's super
computational heavy and we don't know
yet or we will probably never know if we
can do it real time
there is some attempts and they are
super cool so you should definitely
check it out
and ray-tracing gets really complex
quite fast so you're probably not going
to work on a rate racing engine on your
own restoration is really fast so we can
do it easily real time there's lots of
tooling and hardware support so that
means the GPU is actually made to
support your rasterization shaders and
algorithms it's physically incorrect
because as you see we lose through the
perspective projection we lose all the
information about depth and actual
objects which is make it in flat and
therefore we lose quality of the image
how do we do rasterization how could we
get easily started saw before how to get
easily started with ray tracing but now
we want to actually work with
rasterization and get our scenes
together so this is where I want to give
you this toolbox called a frame and it's
really awesome because it's an HTML
component based web framework from
Mozilla basically you can define your
scene with HTML tags and attributes so
for example you can add your sky with an
image reference or you can add rendering
primitives such as boxes sphere
cylinders etc by just defining positions
with and other things so colors
materials and you can add lights and the
cool thing about a frame is it comes
with web VR support so you have all the
major headsets that are supported from
the get-go which also means that you
have controller support so I could look
for example like this it's really boring
though so what do we do with it I mean
still the primitives it's not very
exciting
that's where the community comes in so
lots of people from the community have
been writing components custom
components that work super well and here
you can see how we we would we would
load such a component so it's just
basically loading a script source the
first one is a frame that we have that
we want to use then the second one is 3d
i/o is the framework we are working on
then we have some community examples
like orbit controls which controls like
an object that could go around something
else and we have an environment
component which is really cool I'll show
you later what it looks like
so this is how our scene would for
example be defined we can use the custom
a frame components to load objects or to
define for example in the environment at
the bottom we could define presets that
we want to be using and really quickly
with a few lines of code you get
something like this you get a really
nice scene very dreamy you could just
lay down and put your VR headset on and
enjoy it and I have to say even if you
are not familiar with 3d modeling you
don't have to it's it's really a big
overhead to get started with modeling
it's like I know that from my from my
learning it it's really a hard and steep
learning curve so this is way more fun
to get started and then you can see if
that's something you would like to
integrate in your product or if you want
to just get started and try to work with
it which leads me to the problem of
where do I get my content from what do I
do
I don't I can't do 3d modeling I don't
know where to get proper resources from
and also I don't know what is actually
good 3d content I don't know what makes
a good 3d asset what's me what makes a
bad one
and there we have a few things that you
can do so for example this is a frames
inspector which is also something that I
can really highly recommend comes with a
frame so you actually have a 3d
inspector where you can place your
objects and one of my co-workers was
writing this plugin where I can load 3d
models from google polly
or from our from our library and
hopefully later on much more curated
content and you can just drag and drop
them in your scene and then copy the
attributes into your HTML because it's
HTML based you can also just use
JavaScript to animate any of the of the
attributes you want and as you see here
you can even just define an animation
for line you could just add an animation
to any entity in your scene without any
JavaScript sorry
script folks you don't need it but you
can make it much cooler because you can
then make interactive things so I would
like to wrap this up take away for
everybody that gets started is your
multi models matter your materials
matter a lot because if you don't define
your materials properly you're gonna
lose lots and lots of quality of your
product so your scene might look really
planned it might look gray it does not
get interesting when you interact with
lights
so please please remember this and also
your lighting matters so if you define
your lights wrong in your scene it's
gonna look really flat and sadly I don't
have the time to make a little
introduction of that but if you're
curious just come to me later and we can
have a look at it also ray tracing is
really cool I really love doing ray
tracing but it is still not ready I
think to be used in real time
however you can use the you can use ray
tracing engines to pre-compute
realistic lights so if you remember the
scene from the beginning there was
actually a light map baked into the
model which means we have textures that
contain the light information from a ray
tracing engine that has been doing this
computation for like an hour or so and
that's something that we also offer in
our product that's something I am
working on is that we take a generic 3d
model and we take the generic light
setup that you choose and we basically
bake it in your scene statically these
are techniques from computer
sorry game development that are really
going to be helpful for the web they are
seen and for everybody who works with
web we are so for that thank you very
much for your attention and echidnas are
awesome there are my new favorite
animals thank you so much for having me
and this is how to get started
[Applause]
you